this isn't why claiming that the
criticism is fake news so I want to
congratulate all of you for the
important work you are doing or in
trying to make the American people
moment in American history not only are
we going to take on trump's lock eyes
and his hatred and his racism and his
sexism and its homophobia and in
xenophobia and his religious bigotry
other than that I think he's doing a
pretty good job but the way we take him
on is by doing exactly the opposite of
what he is trying to do he's trying to
divide us up by the color of our skin
where we were born and when our campaign
is bringing people together black and
white and Latino asian-american Native
American gay and straight native born
immigrant Iraq found a progressive
agenda which demands that we have an
economy and a government that works for
all and not just the 1% and uniquely
this campaign is prepared to tell Wall
Street and the insurance companies and
the drug companies and the
military-industrial complex
and the fossil fuel industry that they
can no longer determine all that have
polity which to my mind is a very very
very serious issue facing this country
it is unacceptable to me that three
people now own more wealth than the
bottom half
of the American people that at a time
when so many of our people are working
two or three jobs forty-nine percent of
all new income goes to the top one
percent we got to talk about that issue
and we got to deal with that issue but
in the midst of that massive disparity
between the very very rich in everybody
else there is another kind of disparity
that exists and that is the racial
disparity in America so today we are
living in a country which as all of you
know we're white families owned ten
times more wealth than black family we
are living in a country where when 87
million Americans are uninsured or
underinsured the situation is far worse
in the african-american community where
maternal deaths women giving birth three
times higher than for white women weight
infant mortality is two and a half times
higher where there clearly are not
enough black doctors black nurses black
psychiatrists social workers so when we
talk about disparity we talk about
national crises but we understand the
disparity within the african-american
impacting the african-american community
and that means hundreds of thousands of
bright young kids cannot afford to go to
college because of their limited income
of their family it is a crisis which
disproportionately impacts African
American young people who twelve years
after they leave school find themselves
more in debt than when they took out
their student debt in the first place so
when we have a national
Colonel is about four years ago I talked
about raising the minimum wage to a
living wage 15 bucks an hour people said
that was a wild that was extreme
couldn't be done since then seven states
have done that in as you know several
weeks ago the US House of
Representatives passed a $15 an hour
minimum wage and when we do that and
it's president I will certainly do that
that means we address the crisis where
half half of African American workers
today are making less than $15 and I
will be a raise
the half of African American workers and
when I talk about the need to make
public colleges and universities
tuition-free when I talk about the need
to cancel student debt that impacts the
entire country it will
disproportionately impact the African
American community and when I talk about
and we've made huge progress on this
over the last four years that we must
understand and the American people do
understand that health care is a human
right not a privilege and this is
something that will impact every
American no more deductibles no both
co-payments no more out-of-pocket
expenses no more seeing a half a million
Americans every year go bankrupt for the
crime of having been sick and having a
large medical bill that will impact the
entire country it will significantly
impact the african-american community
and when we talk about criminal justice
when we talk about ending a criminal
justice system that is not only broken
but is racist we are talking about
investing in african-american and
minority communities so the kids have
the education and the job training that
they need so that they will not in
highly disproportionate numbers end up
in jail four years ago I talked about
ending the war on drugs and legalizing
marijuana which is a major in I'm happy
to tell you as you know state after
state is moving in that direction this
is a national issue it is an African
American issue because for people who
smoke marijuana and it's about equally
distribute
between the white community in the black
community if you're black you're six
times more likely to be arrested today
in America 20% of the people in jail
unbelievably are in jail for the crime
of being poor they cannot afford cash
bail we're going to eliminate cash bail
in this country senator okay let's go
[Applause]
thank you
I didn't mean the Ducks good leave me in
the catch off there you're not the first
a lot of broadcast journalists in the
room we know how to hit a commercial
break let's let's start with your
medicare-for-all plan because one of the
things I noticed at the debate last week
on a on another network there there
seems to be among Democrats right now
you seem to be quite divided there seem
to be two camps and it's maybe a bit of
an oversimplification but there there
seem to be candidates like Bernie
Sanders who who believe that health care
is a human right and that Medicare
should be readily available to all
Americans some have even said
undocumented immigrants there seems to
be some confusion at least there was
last last week over precisely how you
would pay for that can you clear that
wrong do you mind if I stand sure did
you bring props
the question is how we pay for it
well the answer is we are already paying
for it let's be clear in my view this is
not really a debate about health care
this is a bait debate about profits and
greed
health care system is working fantastic
if you are the pharmaceutical industry
where 10 companies made 69 billion in
profits when one out of five Americans
cannot afford the medicine they need
system is working great if you are the
insurance industry where the top 5
insurance companies make 23 billion in
profits last year over the last 30 of
the last 20 years the health care
industry has spent over four billion
dollars in lobbying and campaign
contributions to give us a system in
which 87 million are uninsured or
underinsured where we pay the highest
prices in the world for prescription
drugs where a half a million people go
bankrupt with medical bills every year
this is not a debate about a rational
healthcare system this is a debate about
whether we have the guts to take on the
health care industry which is enormous
ly powerful so how do you pay for it we
are now spending twice as much per
capita on health care as do the people
of any other country in Canada
you got any doctor you want you have
heart surgery you're in the hospital for
a month you come out there is no bill
there is no bankruptcy health care is a
human right they spend 50% of what we
spend so the way you pay for it is I'm
sorry the Canadian economy is much
smaller in the American economy far
fewer people in Canada the United States
so he's easy Peter callosities
absolutely I mean that's not you know
when you talk about Germany you talk
about UK let's be clear we are the only
country on Earth that doesn't guarantee
health care to all people as a right
what other countries do and what we have
got to do is pay for this through public
financing
and come up with a progressive tax
system that says that at a time of
massive income and wealth inequality yet
the wealthy and large corporations are
going to pay more and at the end of the
day according to every study that I have
seen at the end of the day Medicare for
all will cost the American people less
than the current dysfunctional system
and our plan will cost it the
overwhelming majority of the American
people less than they're paying for
health care right now
now what part okay part of this health
care discussion is also about abortion
and reproductive rights and reproductive
this year alone we have seen several
states thanks to their
republican-controlled state legislatures
passing some of the most strict
restrictions on abortion I've seen in my
short lifetime yes why is it important
for a woman to have the ability to
choose whether or not to get an abortion
and if you were elected president how
would you ensure that we would have that
right as we've seen these state
legislatures do what they want to do
regardless of who's in office well
Austin we could dance to adjustment to
be clear as somebody who has the 100%
pro-choice lifetime voting record we do
something which was controversial in the
midst of controversy and that is writing
this Medicare fraud bill what we say is
reproductive rights are health care and
that means that every woman in America
under a medicare-for-all single-payer
program will have the right to have an
abortion and other reproductive issues
dealt with so we covered that now why is
it you know I get very tired of the
hypocrisy of some of my conservative
colleagues who say you know we believe
in small government we believe in
getting the government off your back
right that's what they believe
apparently except when it comes to a
woman having the right to control her
own body so you know all I can say is
you know
it is your body it is not the body of a
politician in Washington or a state
capitol or a local government this is a
difficult decision women and their
physicians will make different decisions
but at the end of the day this is a
decision for the women of this country
and not the politicians senator you
mentioned another tightly connected
issue with in reproductive justice in
your opening remarks which you talked
about the maternal and infant mortality
crisis among black folks now I know
Medicare for all is your platform for
dealing with problems like this but we
know from studies that this is a crisis
that affects women who have insurance as
well right and we also know that what
one of the main predictors of maternal
mortality is the experience of racism
not necessarily economic injustice or
lack of access to health care what do
you have planned to deal with this
aspect of maternal mortality and this
reproductive justice after agree with
you absolutely look there's no question
but that when the day comes and it will
come and I hope sooner or later where
healthcare is a right for all people we
are going to make a lot of progress in
terms of infant mortality and maternal
health but your point is well-taken and
that is on top of all of the other
healthcare crises that we face we do
face the problems of racism and we do
place prey face the problem that in
african-american communities among other
things there are not enough black
doctors there are not enough black
nurses or other black professionals and
that ties so what we have got to do is
focus a special attention on those
distressed communities where health care
outcomes are bad and that is exactly
what we will be doing and it's not just
urban areas it is rural areas as well
when you have a healthcare system which
is not designed to make profits for
insurance companies to provide quality
care for all you have the freedom to ask
the question why is infant mortality
rate why are the maternal death rates
for black women high
and we can focus and put resources into
that well one area that we really do
have to be aggressive on is making sure
that there are more african-american
health care professionals right now in
underserved areas than we have and that
is exactly what we will do with Medicare
for all I want to go back to something
that you you mentioned you've talked a
lot about canceling student debt
yes addition to free four year tuition
at public universities and colleges but
specifically on canceling student debt
as someone who just maybe two or three
years ago finished paying off his
student debt how how is it how is it
fair to those who sacrificed mightily
four years to pay off their student debt
all of a sudden decide that the
government should step in and swoop in
and forgive a few trillion dollars in
student debt I'm asking I'm asking
objectively for a friend
the
see what he's angry about is we meet
will you come up with that idea 10 years
ago right Wow all right look let me
rephrase your question how's that sure
Darren how is it possible that the
United States Congress 11 years ago
provided the largest bailout in history
for the crooks and I use that word
advisedly on Wall Street who destroyed
our economy and not only a 700 billion
dollar bailout but trillions of dollars
in zero which responds how is it
possible and under Trump few years ago
the Congress needless to say against my
vote gave over a trillion dollars in tax
breaks to the top one percent in large
private corporations right that's what
happens when people have power Wall
Street has power the billionaire class
has power the forty five million people
who are carrying student that I just
talked to some young african-american
kids today who are dealing with that
debt kids who cannot get married and
have kids kids cannot buy a home can't
even buy a car that their whole life is
being structured around the fact that
they have to pay these oppressive debts
every single month so here's my view we
told this generation Millennials we said
go out and get a college education and
many of them did right and you're wet
deeply into debt right and that that is
oppressing every decision you make is
that right all right we're doing well
here all right and the answer is the
answer is it seems to me that in the
richest country in the history of the
world when we give tax breaks to
billionaires and bail out Wall Street
that we got to give this generation a
chance the truth is the millennial
generation for the first time in the
modern history of this country will have
a lower standard of living than their
parents their caring's
the answer I am answering the question
and that I think instead of bailing out
Wall Street and giving tax breaks to
billionaires we should save an entire
Millennial Generation and give them a
shot for a decent life that's my answer
can we can we also for future reference
not scream out questions from the
audience just for future reference
so you touch the nerve there I think wow
I do but but but but to be fair how
would you decide who gets the bailout
how would you decide which college
student how much money and I mean that's
a good question and we thought about it
and we thought the simplest fair is the
most effective way to do it was to
cancel all student debt for forty five
million people now you might ask which
is a fair question it is a fair question
that's a lot that program making public
colleges and universities tuition-free
and canceling all student that is about
a two point two trillion dollar costs
over a 10-year period which is a lot of
money how do we raise the money well we
raised the money by imposing a
relatively small tax on Wall Street
speculation all right Wall Street last
year the top six banks debate one
hundred and ten billion dollars in
profits they were bailed out by the
American people after they caused severe
harm to our economy they can afford a
small tax that tax will more than make
up the cost of making all public
colleges and universities tuition-free
and canceling student debt look I
understand that not everybody here
agrees something but at the end of the
day what I believe is when you have a
massive level of income and wealth
inequality when so many people are
struggling where you got forty million
people living in poverty while a handful
of people have unbelievable wet well
yeah I do believe and the essence of
what I am fighting for is to create an
economy which says to those people on
top you are gonna have to start paying
your fair share of taxes you can't stash
your profits and the case
Islands and in Bermuda and we are going
to create an economy that works for all
of us so people want to be critical
I got it but that is what I believe now
senator in your previous answer
you mentioned millennia in your previous
answer
you mentioned Millennials yes right I
actually believe probably about half of
this room is younger than Millennials
this is Gen Z now right a lot of be
careful where you read no no I want to
ask is
a lot of your message is carried over
from 2016 when you mean is Bernie you're
really repetitious you keep saying the
same thing and the answer is it's true
and my response to that is that when we
address the massive level of income and
wealth inequality when we address a
corrupt political system in which a
handful of billionaires can spend
hundreds of millions of dollars to elect
candidates to represent the wealthy in
the battle powerful when finally the
United States joins every other major
country on earth and guarantees
healthcare to all people when we make
public colleges and universities
tuition-free okay when we cancel student
debt when we tackle the existential
crisis of climate change you know what
I'll stop talking about those issues
all right but that is what we have got
to do I know media likes a new story
every day sorry that's not my style and
what we have got to do is focus on why
things are I want everybody to think
about think about asking me how does it
happen
and after all of the campaign's or all
of the speeches and all of the party
platforms the average American worker is
not making a nickel more today than he
or she did 45 years ago how does it
happen that over the last thirty years
there has been the richest 1% of seeing
a 21 percent 21 trillion dollar increase
in their wealth bottom half of America
seen a decline and they were how does
that happen do we talk about it in
Congress no did we talk about it in the
media No
why not these are the issues that have
got to be discussed we are the
wealthiest country in the history of the
world and we do not need to have people
sleeping out on the streets we do not
need to have people spending half of
their limited incomes on housing we do
not need to have kids suffering under
oppressive student debt we do not have
to see black mothers dying in childbirth
and rates that are unfathomable in terms
of the developed world this is the
richest country in the world
and finally we're gonna have to say and
I know this is sensitive I know people
are like the hearing but you gotta
finally say to the people who own this
country who control our economy who
control our politics they cannot have it
all we are going to create an economy
that works for all of us
[Music]
let's play a hypothetical game you win
the election and become president
Republicans can maintain control of the
Senate Mitch McConnell has said he will
be the grim reaper and veto anything
that comes to his desk that looks like a
socialist democratic policy how will you
get any of these things passed in
Congress if Republicans still control
the Senate a very brief answer senator
yes okay we will do it the way
wheelchairs always taken place and that
is rally millions of people in
McConnell's own state of Kentucky which
happens to be a poor state by the way to
demand that their elected officials
thought listening to them rather than
campaign contributors quick question on
immigration questions we've seen this
humanitarian crisis at the border what
is one thing that must change to avoid
that crisis moving forward um we've got
to do away with these privately-owned
detention centers we will not as a
nation under a Bernie Sanders presidency
be ripping tiny babies from the arms of
their mothers and we will pass
comprehensive immigration reform senator
Sanders thank you thank you for coming
you have two minutes oh okay if you'd
like to make symposium on
[Applause]
look-the I know that not everybody in
the room agrees with everything I say
right but at the end of the day what my
campaign is about is asking pretty
simple questions how does it happen that
in countries around the world every
major country health care is a human
right and they spent a fraction per
capita of what we spend doesn't happen
how does it happen that 10 days ago I
took a trip to Canada with people who
are dealing with diabetes and they were
able to buy insulin for one tenth of the
price charged in the United States of
America how does it happen that we have
a system where the Koch brothers and a
handful of billionaires can spend
hundreds of millions of dollars buying
elections how does it happen that we
have half of our people living paycheck
to paycheck and the reality that we have
got to deal with which is an
uncomfortable reality a reality not
discussed in Congress far too rarely
discussed in the media is that you have
a corporate elite in this country who
could care less about the average
working-class person in this country who
are consumed by greed who are not happy
enough that the top 1% now owns more
wealth than the bottom 92% they want
more they want more tax breaks they want
to cut Social Security Medicare Medicaid
and education and what this campaign is
about is in fact as you mentioned is a
political revolution it's not just
getting me elected it is bringing
millions of people to stand up and fight
for change in the only way that change
has ever taken place whether it is the
labor movement the women's movement the
civil rights movement the gay rights
movement those changes never took place
from the top on down always from the
bottom on up when millions of people
stood up and fought for economic justice
racial justice social justice and that's
what this campaign is about
thank you all very much
[Music]
[Applause]